what's up struggle nation welcome to the
real rejects
we're here because drew promoted that he
would be on the real rejects channels
those videos just for you guys
if you haven't heard of me I don't know
how you haven't he's famous
I mean Magna sites are everywhere
everyone knows the name Tyrone Magnus
with me Zak asan we're gonna kick some
ass today alright we're gonna watch Cora
Cruz VFX artists react to that and great
CGI number 10 quarters on the best
YouTube channels struggle nation is one
of the best reaction channels in the
world so happy you could be here thanks
for driving all the way from
Philadelphia just to be on this channel
and come in its own I know how worth it
it is to finally be able to collab with
me blasphemous HD I will escape Grand
Theft Auto to come here and I'm looking
forward to seeing Clint's reaction to it
all
I can't wait to react really taking me
off guard because it's like he's missing
half his face and it looks incredibly
real and that's what makes this so
jarring is because you
actually see inside of his cheek so--but
yes never seen eyeball just exposed like
that it emits this visceral reaction of
like oh you can see his tendons like oh
oh
gathers ooh it on it a lot of people
like to say that Christopher Nolan does
not like visual effects you only ever
does practical effects but I'm sure
stellar and in stellar in the 90s wooden
people started doing holy crap I
remember this I owned this right well
once you trying starting to make things
photorealistic we saw me realize that
that didn't look real because that's not
how our skin moves around
we have muscles underneath Oh Pixar time
when they're tight they're gonna bulge
out and they're loose they're gonna say
hospitals and our skin is just on top of
this web of muscles and tendons that are
pulling things around so we're something
like too much school you need that
complexity of the muscles underneath
pulling you Steve attended sliding
against each other and it's all hand
animated by the way it's just a
testament to us starting to understand
how to animate humans and human faces
what did they have like any tracking
markers what do they do there so
Christopher Nolan likes to shoot his
movies with a lot of Darkness right and
you've probably seen facial tracking
where they have little black dots in the
face you're not going to see the black
dots in his face when he's in shadow so
they're using little white markers but
even then those aren't shadow right they
fall into shadow and you lose that so
they're actually doing to track his face
it's not the main camera that's tracking
his face they actually have other
cameras on set and they have little ring
lights around another very well and
that's all retro reflective material all
those other colors fascinating vibrant
bright dots even when it's in shadow
because of the retro reflective material
Wow
it's a really ingenious way to have
motion tracking dots that you can see
with multiple cameras but not the main
camera when using multiple cameras you
can triangulate the positions of those
dots and get 3d motion tracking data out
of it so that's how the tracking is
faced to put the 3d model on it she's
not about what I want it's about what's
burger
spoiler is he from hopefully you've seen
the movie by now you guys seen where
he's dead and really rockin his face
back and forth his resting expression he
looks like he's smiling yeah blank
there's happy there's happy Harvey Dent
is like wait that's no good he's
supposed to be sad now oh god no his
eyeball toward the dragon's eyeballs are
but instead his eyes turn into teeth
[Music]
here's the thing there's a big
difference between bad visual effects
and old visual effects and artists
dropping the ball producers getting too
in the way of artists trying to do their
thing but with old digital effects it's
just the limitation of the technology
and so like you know you got more to see
out your basic transitions you can't
really get too crazy with particles
because you didn't have the computer
power for it back in base but one thing
they could have done is added a light
that flickered at the same rate as
lightning oh yeah yeah look at that like
everything is super bright except for
him he doesn't flicker at all that would
have taken these VFX shots to the next
level it's a t-rex aim from Jurassic
Park like they didn't have the fancy
lighting technology for that either
what they did to make up for it was that
they had very specific lighting
situations that you can replicate in a
computer and they had that same thing
going here but they don't so much it's a
fun movie and at the end of the day even
if the visual effects
[Music]
now if we're not Alesha I know First
Avenger look at him he's right they're
so skinny
this is like the perfect example of
their effect I never learned how they
did this game yeah I didn't either
Chris Evans was ripped during all the
rent yeah cuz he was playing the final
version of himself and they didn't have
the time for him to like skinny down and
then buff up
so all these shots of skinny Chris Evans
are actually totally buffed out for
sevens
wait are you free it's not just a skinny
guy oh yes and no when actually shot the
movie they would shoot three different
takes and so they would shoot the
original shot with Chris Evans buffed
out Chris Evans so they would shoot a
second time with an actual actor who is
a tiny dude but the effects company
would basically just use him as
reference and only reference and then
they would also do a third take with no
one than this shot at all like a clean
plate damn that's a lot of the same shot
the whole movie whoa heavy so first
things first like this scene right here
that you're seeing the split screen
that's a straight-up liquefying to store
it and shrinking everything down like
maybe his arm skinny making his chest in
E and just straight-up distorting your
frame that scene that where he goes and
talks to the the doctor from being
recruited that's a body double and so
times one is just like skin and he's not
wearing a shirt that's the double
basically this is an example of where
they used the smaller actor in composite
in Chris Evans his face on top of his
they just do a head replacement here
they made me even skinnier because
apparently a small Steve Rogers is still
several inches shorter than the small
actor they used on set this is all 2d
compositing they use a program called
flame for all of it the same flame that
was first used on the Super Mario
Brothers movie oh God
so the company that does this visual
effects is called Lola visual effects I
think they're in London but they're
responsible for all of the details in
social network you know you have Russell
Stark wow they really specialized in
trying to like figure out what parts of
the body sag and so that they know what
parts they like soften up and smooth out
you definitely know something I got here
sir
Patrick Stewart when they smooth them
over it definitely kind of gives them
that smooth look it kind of looks less
real because it is so artificially
smooth and you lose some of the detail
in my highlights you can still see the
wrinkles there that reminds me actually
of something that's really unique about
the Steve Rogers speed Steve Rogers so
we have texture our skin you know you
have skid plates you have hair follicles
basically grain right detail what
happens when you take something that's
this big and you scale it down what
happens if you take a big picture you
scale it down it gets sharper right it
gets crisper so all of that gave him a
problem when when they started shrinking
him down all the texture on him started
getting really crisp you can tiny
compared to everything else okay yeah so
they actually had to did after they
shake him down the head to basically
denoise his skin that's gotta be a lot
of work and grain and noise back to his
game at the correct scale another layer
is really hard for a low-budget movie
big colleges are more these shadows
coming in wrong they would be shadowed
the shot would kind of lift the shadows
everywhere and then they would shrink it
down cuz they oh yeah like you're saying
they just shrink it down with the
shadows it's like those shadows come
from it it was a tremendous amount of
work no wonder that guy working on for
sure and like this is true mastery of
like the human form if you ever wonder
why early now da Vinci cuts up in
cadavers if you can understand the
anatomy in the muscular structure then
you know what's the draw when you're
drawing something from referencing from
your mind so as you know you can always
leave a comment down below I need to cut
up since our bodies next I'm not dirty
for that way to interact with us we run
a poll on patreon every VFX artists
react for you guys to pick one of our
scenes and skinny Steve Rogers was one
of them so consider supporting us on
patreon
there's a link in the description below
alright let's check out the next one
okay old short movie hater this movie
I've never seen this first in the way
ever fell asleep one yeah any other Mia
Jovovich yep I don't know this movie
good good good I'd rather watch this
good and there's trying to make it good
and turned out bad and that's hilarious
to watch in ultraviolet is a case of the
latter look at those those particles
shooting out of the side of the building
that when she's goes straight up are
they tracked or not she's right that
doesn't drift why are they drifting so
mad theater some poor artists I'm sure
is having to hand track this into this
shot way after the fact with no tracking
data I think you're right Nico I think
the motorcycle is 100% real yeah I think
they're just having to deal with the the
footage plates of that because
everything is green screen here it was
that an attempted retiming there - yeah
now you gotta watch it all the pyramids
are just spewing out steam in the
background all the pyramids they
brothers steaming out
whoa whoa that was cool the gun it's too
late man dude the smooth skin filter is
killing me moving took photoshop's on
the shark mask filter and applied it for
their look unsharp mask us right now
just just make us look like ultraviolet
there you have it they didn't get one
thing right the helicopter blade motion
blur is making the blue of the sky
darker not just great yeah good for them
how did they get that right well they
can't trick in particles because you
have like five VFX artists staying up 24
hours a day just trying to get this done
yeah yep what's going on by the way guys
this whole movie is gold please watch
this movie next time you get a chance
watching it at one-and-a-half speed with
the sound still on is the preferred way
to walk okay I'm gonna do that now yeah
what is this show this is the beginning
of all of you pause this video right now
and go watch this we'll see you what is
this I love this wow what is this
did the way his eye cracks in the blood
before this thing like I notice a new
detail every time I watch this see I
know nothing of what is over 40k or
anything like oh we're learn about the
universe or the IP at all but like a fan
film or something
is this a game it might be of the camera
yeah the fan film of the game all of the
modeling and animation and rendering and
compositing and
sound design one guy meeting and
publishing so there's two things that
really it's always one is the fact that
we've gotten to the point
technologically
where one guy has the tools to be able
to make this he's able to make it look
this good Wow pewter secondly is that
there's all these little details being
pulled form Warhammer Lord do use a
pronounced to start tell us about all
the cool details in this you go told me
about this this is basically one of the
cool things I've ever seen I'm a huge
warrior fan so the great thing about
these shorts is that every single aspect
and every single cool action setup piece
is an actual mechanic in the game
realize they use like the plasma pistol
the plasma pistol has like a really high
armor penetration which is why it was
able to get through that the whole like
he zoom you're shooting movement and
then he's doing his charge phase and
then he's doing is combat phase like
this is just like a really sped up
version of playing Warhammer on the
tabletop and make a full length movie
then there they're messing up hard
filled motion blur this looks incredibly
used to have to basically turn on all
these things one by one and dial them in
until they looked real it was all just
hacks so these things that you learned
that physically based rendering program
like octane or redshift octane is our
renderer we love octane it actually
makes it much here make something like
this look real in fact it takes a lot of
the work out octane just turned on put
in a line it's like well that looks
awesome
feels like can I afford that probably no
sciences can simulate it and that's the
beautiful thing about it it just say it
gets technology out of the way for the
artists and just lets artists create
nice that looks incredible yeah it does
see it realizes for
there we go retro
I heard subscribe so that you can find
out when we put it out if you would like
to see us react to a TV show or movies
XEL MMO are a big fan of please leave a
comment down below and we will take a
look yes we've heard all your cuts from
Bollywood favorite shirts quarantine
that store also we've done Instagram
Instagram columns last order digital or
Samson
we'll be working with one day we can
react with him yeah like oh wow I don't
how to contribute to the conversation
wow that was crazy
dad was insane and I found some new
stuff to watch it really highlighted for
me just how much research a VFX artist
has to do really was it was when they
were doing the ultraviolet mode yeah
they were talking about a lot of times
are they covered like things about
physics or whatever motion flow and
whatnot like okay yeah the things that
are generally pretty familiar with hmm
but when they were talking about
ultraviolet and then pointing out the
things that worked like with the
helicopter blades my mom went damn they
just know that like offhand or do you
have to like research something like
that do they teach you that in school or
wherever you're studying this I think
the more you do it then the more you can
pick out and just like you can watch the
TV sure before you do film and it'll be
fun but then after you started actually
record you can pick on all the mistakes
and then true so it's a heightened
awareness you have to certain things the
effects artists are always having to
deal with like brand new things
reporting about the mirror I didn't even
really notice that I didn't notice it
either and it's like I've watched a
movie theater and I hated it and I
couldn't really be technical about the
reasons why but now I see that I'm like
yet none of this worked if you got bad
it was tracked wrong and now I know what
close the reason why I hate the movie
there's a fax did look pretty you'd net
now I gotta watch the movie I think they
said at one point five Tom speed yeah I
got a watch like that now that's how I
watch all the struggle nations videos I
mean we're funny that way yeah it's true
your timing a lot quicker yeah you seem
a lot sharper yeah the setup is like it
takes less time to get to you know we're
trying to get to that for you
I prefer jokes to to speed by okay no
I'll try that I just talk fast in their
video now that's starting now imma be
slower now intentionally go
insert Gregg's punch jump cut when they
were talking about that moment with
two-face I've always appreciated the
detail just like you could see it yeah I
mean to me it's like pretty groceries
another zooming in on the amount of
details
I never something what thing yeah I've
never taken the time to zoom do you
imagine having one of those TVs at home
pots an answer really that they didn't
talk about this but the day made me
think of was the amount of imagination
that aaron eckhart had to channel water
i felt like maybe he had some type of
mask on yeah yeah yeah but the fact that
they just had to dot his face he had to
really utilize his imagination and work
from some weird subconscious feeling of
half of his faces torn off and really
play into that without having any
physical Ning over his whole half of the
face just like dots on it and didn't
feel thought so he didn't even feel
anything on its face exactly make that
up as they went along and make it real
so to me is strangely watching this may
me appreciate Aaron Eckhart's
performance much more because this is
not about any means discredit like he
thought if Joker but I imagine that when
he thought had got into the makeup it
made it easier to perform right likewise
if he had something like that I imagine
would make it easier to do that role but
going purely off imagination for that
it's that's crazy
yeah those effects to lose a lot of
details I didn't even notice before like
the blood on the pillow and everything
later no it's not gonna die this is
really disgusting yeah this is really
good so damn detailed annihilations
effects god no it's just an awful oh the
whole thing is there's no redeeming
quality although that either that's such
a great way that he put it though about
how there's a difference between bad VFX
and just old the offense yeah you know
like the Jumanji effects you can watch
something like that and go that's good
for its time actually and then there are
certain movies like annihilation for
example where it's more than just the
effects don't hold up yeah and if these
effects are really bad yeah because like
there's certain movies where back then
you
had that suspension disbelief like you
know you just let yourself feel along
for the journey you know it wasn't the
best but you were okay with it you look
back on it now like yeah well best but
back then it was bad yeah it was bad
back then and that I'm somebody who I
I watched Battlefield Earth I like that
back then and I watched it now like what
the hell I was even okay with that but
even annihilation I'm like no no uh-uh
Battlefield Earth is what made me become
a Scientologist well then maybe yeah we
can meet Tom Cruise and get me the video
that you get on that you're slacking
don't pull that money I have to pay a
hundred thousand dollars more to get to
level two and then oh that makes sense
sorry you have it though Scientology
fans I've offended 80% of our
demographic our scientology fans well
I'm screwed why does it seem like the
one thing you could make fun of on the
internet and people won't protest you
except for the Church of Scientology
when they're talking about lighting and
how that makes such a big difference
with all these VFX I find that very true
man to me that's the biggest difference
between angley's the Hulk and then the
one would Edward Norton because if you
watch those two films you know like the
whole canang leaves is like a broad
daylight it is super agreed and super
bright and then with the one with ever
Norton they really utilized making
things darker around to make it look
more believable realistic even
spider-man one in spider-man 2 from the
Tobey Maguire versions I noticed when I
watch I was back to back then those did
that as well they really adjusted the
lighting to make it look a lot more
realistic so lighting goes a long way it
really really does the freaking the
Captain America thing I had no idea
that's how they did that I was trying to
figure it out for the longest cuz even
on watch I'm like how the hell did they
do this I thought he just had something
a short guy they just threw his face on
there but then to find out that for so
much of that they had to do two to three
different of the same shot like that is
hard because not only are you dealing
with you know just making sure the same
motion is from the actor mm-hmm but then
you got the other actors like yeah Tom's
and then one time like the actor isn't
even in there
yeah after getting everything else and
then you got buff Chris Evans playing
the whole time and then you take it all
the shadows off you take this picks away
and there
like that some people have made fun of
that moment of the movie for looking a
little cheesy and the way in the way it
came across to me I've always liked it
and watching this video just made me
appreciate it yeah it only looked a
little off when his shirt was off you
know when it sure was enough I thought
it was totally believed yeah watching
this go knowing the amount of just it's
like they were practically reshooting
all the time in order to get this one
portion of the film done it took to get
me because like that's a lot of film and
just dedicated to one character that's
not probably a really big challenge for
the yeah for the actors involved - I
mean technical achievement that is
incredible for actors - like for Hayley
Atwell to have to interact with someone
who's not Chris Evans imagine that's
pretty challenging so that I Captain
America First Avenger is definitely not
high up on my list I mean a the Marvel
movies but this video really enhanced my
appreciate I feel like if I go back and
re-watch it then I'll feel better about
it I have a better appreciation for it
as editor I'm thinking about all that
editing that you had to do just make it
look good and I'm like oh my god
that's insane that is insane this is
great yes it's great Mandy the amount of
detail of things I just don't bother to
think about when I watch and how much
actors have to work around these
technical parameters - and sometimes it
pays off with something like First
Avenger and sometimes and I shouldn't
recommend origins Wolverine you just got
to give it your all work with it oh yeah
I respect these guys these are one of my
favorite channels yeah alright guys well
if you haven't done so already subscribe
to corridor true they're amazing you
guys can subscribe to struggle nation
hashtag struggle nation you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
subscribe to Hakkasan you can subscribe
to tyrone magnus you can subscribe
um dante you can subscribe to buff bunny
subscribe to the movie couple channel
you can subscribe to Jabbok away you
could also subscribe to blasphemous HD
you can subscribe to
Oh farewell farewell you guys just
just do your own thing guys yeah
all right we're done see here click that
noted for days doorbell bye
[Music]